Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Yandere Simulator.
Now in this episode, we're gonna be exploring
some of the new easter eggs that have been added
since the last time that we explored the easter eggs.
So, there's a lot of them
So we're gonna get to 'em. Ready?
EUEUGH!
Right, so first off,
You gotta go in to the menu.
So I gotta...
'Press the D key to disable copyrighted music'
Excellent! Good! Boink!
Alright. So.
Alright.
What did I do?
Oh God!
Oh God, no! I didn't mean to do that!
Ah!
Okay. Hi! Bye- I meant to put..
I meant to push another button.
Not particularly that one!
I'm just trying to get panty shots.
*Creepy laughter*
Somehow that worked.
'Excellent!'
'Now I have Mei Mio's panties.'
'I owe you one for this favor.'
Yeah okay!
I'm not a hundred percent sure that went exactly the way that it was supposed to go.
Heeeey.
How's it going?
Is that Boobs McKenzie?
'Bad Time Mode'
*Sarcastically*
Oh, huh! I wonder who this could be!
'DK Mode' Woah, shit.
Eugh!
I think I've done this before.
But eugh!
Weugh!
Oh God, Senpai!
Woah!
Hey, Senpai!
You've never looked better. Have you been working out?
Wow Senpai, I'm impressed by your incredible biceps.
OH hey, how's it going.
Eugh hehe heh heh heh heh
Hi Boobs McKenzie!
At least your boobs are finally in proportion to the rest of your body.
Nur dur durdilurdlurdurdledurtlur
Normal normal normal normal normal normal normal normal NORMAL
NORMAL
I AM NORMAL
Narwhal narwhal narwhal narwhal narwhal narwhal narwhal narwhal HI!
They...
Aaah!
They changed it!
Ohh! So they actually look like Titans now.
And not just weird...
Ken Doll-like naked people.
Ah, shit.
It's a good thing we got these invisible walls.
Oh, thank you, builders of the city!
Who build these amazing walls to keep the Titans at bay!
Thank the Lord, we are safe!
Hi friends, hello!
Hi! Yes, good! Excellent!
Okay?
Oh no! *'Titan' shrieks*
Aaaah!
Ho-kay.
Alright, WOAH, hey.
Woah, woah, woah hey woah hey
Eugh!
Well...
That's just as disturbing as it was before.
Don't know why that happens.
Okay, I don't know...
I don't know what this is, and
I don't know what it does.
*Dying shriek*
Whoa whoa!
Whoawhoawhoa
Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
Whoa!
WHOA! Whoa whoa!
What the hell happened?
I didn't do that!
Holy shit.
OOOH kay!
Eugh!
Oh god.
I do not know what is happening!
Senpai!
I've become a horrible monster...!
*cries*
Where's Senpai?
*wet inhale*
*long sob*
Hii.
Hey, where'ya goin? Hey, where'ya goin?
Oh no...! *Chuckling*
Oh no. *Laughing sadly*
Oh jeez.
Hi, who're you?
Well, you're dead now.
How sad. It's so sad. Oh ho ho it's so sad.
Hi!
Oh gahd, even the teacher can't withstand me.
Oh no. Oh no!
Sorry!
I- I'm really curious, hang on.
I- I am very curious to see if...
*low murder voice* Hi Senpai.
Hiii.
Senpai!
I know you're too strong for this!
WOAH! OH!
OH!
OOOOOH MY GOODNESS! OH I'M SORRY!
OOOOH!
I DIDN'T THINK IT WAS POSSIBLE TO KILL SENPAI!
WAAH WHAT HAVE I DONE!?
Weagh!
Augh!!
Oh God, the bodies are just piling up beside me!
STOP SPRINTING INTO ME!
*sniffs*
Oh god...
Oh my god, I'm still nervous around his-
Ohh...
Oh no.
Uh oh!
No! Don't do it!
Teach! Teach! Don't do it! Teach! No! No! NO!
Oh, god.
Okay.
Well.
This is... unusual.
Oh!
What have I done? *Sobbing*
I never meant for Senpai to get hurt!
He was my beautiful man!
I truly am a monster...
Oh jeez.
Oh god, what're you?
Oh je- Oh, god! NOO!
OH GOD!
Senpai!
I don't know what I did!
*cries* Oh no no no no!
Oh, someone remove these amazing powers from me!
I don't know what this is from... but wow.
Oh boy
boy don't run moves
Oh, boy.
Don't run, Boobs!
Don't run, Boobsie!
Sorry, sorry everybody.
Sorry.
Ohhh, sorry.
Alright, it's time for my favorite.
The one that I've actually been waiting for.
*Rock music plays*
YEAH! HOOA!
Ok, I gotta test this out.
Hang on!
Hi Teacher!
Hey, what's that erm, over there?
WOAHOHOHOHOHHO
Senpai!
Senpai! Point me to your enemies...
Heya!
Heya! Oh, sorry I missed.
Ha!
Sto- He! AH!
Whoahohohoho
AHAhahahaha
HA HA
Ha HA ha
*laughs*
Where are they going?
HaBAAH!
Oh my god!
Oh, this is everything I had hoped for.
Senpai!
LOVE ME!
SENPAI!
Oh good, I can't kill Senpai like this.
Hi Boobs McKenzie!
HabafKOOOOOOOHOHOHOHOH
Hi Boobsie!
Boobsie!
Boobsie?
Boobsie.
Oh. Oh! Oh!
OH!
Oh god!
Oh god! OH GOD!
What have I done?
Oh jeez! Oh jeez! Oh jeez!
Whoa!
UH!
Boobsie?
Ok, just going to drop that.
Yep, that's fine.
Hello! Hi!
Waaah!
Who the heck is this person?
Who are you?
I've never seen you before!
BOINK! Well, you punch just the same as everybody else!
Oh man...
Boink!
Oh jeez.
Boink! Wait- Boink!
Oh jeez. Boink! Wait...
Boink! Ok, well then.
Oh jeez, it looks like the lockers ate them!
Oh god!
Oh jeez! Oh god!
Hey Senpai, just don't turn around, it's cool.
Die- Hi! You're guarding!
Why Teacher? You're guarding that body!
HABOOFKEY!
Oh boy.
Oh.
Alrighty then. Well!
My job here is done!
Ok! So I accomplished everything that I set out to do in this episode
Which was explore all the avenues of silliness that this game has to offer.
In the next episode, there's a new way of eliminating a rival that involves befriending them.
So in the next episode, I'm going to be
doing that,
and also let me know in the comments whatever you want me to see
to see me do
in this game. So thanks again everyone for watching,
and as always, I will see YOU in the next video!
Buh bye!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]